was that a man or a woman because he
needs a haircut more than I do
I couldn't tell needs a haircut that's
our Donald last night's rally was
nothing new the crowd loved him the
people who already hate him will just
hate him more and the media packs itself
on the head for not covering it while
secretly watching Fox News too bad they
totally missed an opportunity to call
him Hitler so for the bias impaired
here's News Trump just reduced the risk
of nuclear war he also got remains of
200 US soldiers back from North Korea
just a week after the issue was raised
he's bringing in record low unemployment
helping women in minorities most he's
addressed trade imbalances as our GDP
climbs higher so if he's a monster
he might be the worst monster ever
meaning not a monster at all
that's why optimism is high 95% of
manufacturers have a positive company
outlook it's good news even if the
elites deny it and about those elites
you ever noticed they always call the
other side and they do this up but the
elite the elite why are they elite I
have a much better apartment than they
do
[Music]
I'm smarter than they are I'm richer
than they are I became president and
they didn't
and I'm representing the greatest
smartest most loyal best people on earth
the deplorable z-- remember that that's
key now bragging is never appealing but
he's not wrong that by wealth he's an
elitist yet he's still embraced by
working classes
no wonder the De Niro's the Madonna's
debts and fond is all unravel Trump's
richer than them all but closer to the
street than they are how can that be the
answer is he makes promises and fights
to keep them and besides for you
deplorable z-- at the rally the outraged
celebrity class will always deem you to
be the uncool kids Trump defends you
against the jerks so it's not about
wealth or apartments it's about speaking
up for people that the media celebrity
complex Snickers at and it's why when
everything seems to be working out those
Snickers seem truly from Mars
you like that Dana are you like those
silly little puns
is it Donald Trump a bit like your rich
uncle always telling you're why can't
your buddy
get a haircut like it's tight short
haircut like that it is like my aunt
Donna yes one who does the haircuts in
the kitchen yeah have a couple weeks
there you know what I was thinking about
today who I was just trying to have one
other person who had this ability
somebody was successful wealthy a
celebrity but who was still considered a
blue collar me came up with I came up
with Clint Eastwood oh yeah and I think
it's partly because of the art that he
chose right the way that he chose to for
the movies he directed the how he acted
the things that he did and there's not
many others yeah he speaks the language
Jesse and it's like but I want to go
back to the haircut thing sure because I
believe the haircut thing is about being
presentable for a job that's how a
Salesman thing it's like you get a
haircut Jesse you clean it up yeah but
he's also a trans man and you know you
speak about these man buns and you could
mock a man bun now in 2018 we still can
do that and the rest of the people are
afraid to talk about other people's
appearance because they may be being
accused of being insensitive
Trump's never been afraid of being
called
insensitive right so he's he's like the
common man for a few reasons one he's
dealt with contractors all his life
remember he's like I can smell a
contractor but it's true you know as a
real estate developer you deal with the
pipe fitters the Masons the electrical
engineers and he's great at that and he
also eats fast food not for a photo op
because he actually likes it he speaks
in a blunt brash style that connects
with the average American and to be guys
he's kind of that aspirational celebrity
for many generations people in the rest
of the country looked up to Donald Trump
they liked the women he was around they
liked the planes they liked the style
they liked the Jets and if you want to
become rich in America he wanted to be
like Donald Trump and let's not forget
before he ran for president
athletes wanted to live in Trump Tower
all the real estate guys they wanted
some you know tea times it is called
most sighted celebrity and rap music
exactly and all the advertising
executives they wanted a piece of the
action
this guy was it and then the minute he
runs for president he's Hitler
you know Trump deals with Mason's not
Freemasons all right why I know why I
was like the elitist establishment
versus the everyday man
that explains it Dana my mom side are
you part of the Trilateral Commission
Wyoming what I know you love that rally
you recorded it and played it five times
the question is the apartment yes his
apartments better than 0.9 a smarter
richer he has a better apartment he also
lives in the West Wing oh you talk about
a petty person
that's him that's what the way he has I
got a better apartment so how come on
own ality everything so let me try to
explain it what he was saying he was
trying to say that he's he could be in
that group but you love me and I love
you that's what I got him no no no I
tell you what it wasn't insulting to
anybody no I think it was worthy of
mockery I tell you that because my
apartments bigger than yours my buttons
bigger than you I mean this is the way
he talks who he is I'm just saying you
asked about how he relates to people he
say well oh these other celebrities they
don't have the support of the working
man let me just tell you something I'm
not sure he has the support of the
working man on separating children from
parents I don't think he has the support
of the working man yet what he does is
he pushes brought him together now
button issues and fear and he says you
know what you can hate Hillary Clinton
he had the crowd last night chanting
lock her up right yeah who can say he
can say things like oh go home to your
mom to this guy why don't we why don't
you get a haircut
I don't know if that's a man or a woman
that is a terrible impression one he
hates on everybody and then he says you
know what maybe those Hispanics that was
immigrants they're terrible - they're an
infant he ms-13 his appeal is based on
hateful language and he appeals to the
worst insult okay so we're all bad
people Kimberly I don't know I think
America is great I think the president
was saying that last night what an
incredible country and the supporters
and trying to do something he's actually
followed through and has had tremendous
accomplishments like we've reiterated
numerous times on this show and I don't
know I for myself in terms of as a
Puerto Rican woman and looking at other
minorities are quite pleased the numbers
are going up in terms of know in terms
of their favorability about the
president yes and you see key numbers
going down unemployment why wouldn't
somebody be happy about that lower
unemployment for women for minorities
for Hispanics for blacks Isis gone we've
got record job number and Kimberly's
apartments nicer
John member last night he not only was
attacking Pelosi and Clinton he then
goes after John McCain a smile you did
watch the role I can read